well guys I'm freaking pissed off today
why well uh so I basically recorded this
video earlier and uh just because I've
just moved again I'm actually back in
the US now of course I didn't have my
microphone set up properly and I go to
edit the [__] video and uh there's no
audio and so I'm now looking at this
video uh thinking to myself well [__] I
just popped two Edibles and now I have
to re-record a 10 minute YouTube video
on systems design so uh this should go
really well and uh I'm hoping it does
and let's get into it but before we do I
should probably quickly announce that uh
I guess we've just reached the one year
anniversary in the channel so I'd like
to thank everyone for their subscription
and watching and just in general being
very supportive you guys are great in
the comments and it's clear that
everyone's taking this very seriously
and following along and interviewing
themselves so thanks again for all the
support let's get into this video so I
can finish this before I get high
alrighty welcome back everybody I've got
the iPad on my lap I just deleted all
the annotations and markings that I did
with it before which is great and uh
let's go ahead and start talking about
this video so that uh I can get it out
before I forget what replication is so
basically to start we have this concept
of a single leader replication so in the
past couple videos we talked about what
replication is why we might need it and
also synchronous versus asynchronous
replication so for the purpose of this
video I'm going to assume we're
generally using asynchronous replication
because synchronous replication
generally speaking is not very practical
there are some scenarios where you do
need to do it if you have to ensure that
you can never have a stale read but I'd
say 99 of the time you're probably not
replicating synchronously so let's go
ahead and assume that every time I write
a dotted line with an arrow such as this
one here that means asynchronous
replication so what is single leader
replication well it's known as a
replication schema which basically means
that it's a way of sending rights to the
database and then basically reading from
it later so we've got our client over
here and it's going to perform a right
to our leader database so the point of
the leader is that all rights no matter
who is sending them have to go to our
leader database however we also have
many follower databases as you can see
we've got one here we've got one here
and basically as they asynchronously
receive rights from the leader any other
client including the original writer
such as this guy over here can perform a
read from them and the same client can
perform a read from this database down
here it can perform a read from the
leader itself so again it gives us a lot
more opportunities to increase our read
throughput so let's actually go into a
breakdown of what single leader
replication achieves for us so basically
there is a couple of benefits and then
we'll break those down a little bit more
even so basically number one most
importantly is increased durability we
have many copies of our data now and it
means that if I were to take a nuke and
go nuke one of our data centers we still
have a few other copies of that data
which is great
additionally we also have increased read
throughput this is a result of what I
showed over here so in this case as
opposed to having just you know normal
read throughput from the leader itself
we're also adding two followers which
gives us three times as much read
throughput which is great and it's
basically for free right all we have to
do is just add a couple of extra
databases which are asynchronously
reading rights in the background so it's
pretty easy to go and extend our system
to support single leader replication
so let's look at a couple of failure
scenarios because the entire point of
replication aside from increasing read
throughput and sometimes but not in this
case increasing right throughput is to
basically make sure that in the event of
failures we still have a working system
so let's look at a couple of these so
one type of failure scenario is our
follower goes down right let me zoom in
here so we don't get distracted and so
let's say we have one follower right
here and I go ahead and trip over some
wire and now I've pulled the plug on it
so pulled
plug
here we go so now we're down one less
follower let's imagine that right before
the follower went down we know that it's
seen all rights up to position 50 in our
replication log right so we have this
concept of a log that can just be stored
on disk and that log is being sent
basically from the leader to all the
followers right and so we can actually
keep track on every single follower what
the last position that they've seen on
the replication log is and so let's say
this guy goes down and we know that it's
at position 50 right over here let's now
say though that eventually I realized
that I pulled the plug out on this thing
I get up you know I put a Band-Aid on my
knee because I tripped and then we go
ahead and see that hey the leader is at
position 70. well now what the leader
can actually do is just go ahead and
send rights from 51
to 70 all the way to our basically newly
revived follower and then he can be
caught back up and so what's great now
is that this guy is back up to date
after only a little bit of time so when
a follower does go down in a single
leader replication situation this is
super easy to deal with happens all the
time to be expected on the other hand
when a leader goes down we've got many
many challenges to deal with so let's
discuss basically three different
scenarios of things that can go wrong
when a leader goes down and we'll kind
of explain why this is such a big deal
in a single leader replication setup
so let's look at scenario one over here
in the top left so I'll even zoom in on
it for us so basically let's imagine
that we've got one follower over here
and he thinks that the leader is dead
right because maybe just the network
connection between the leader and
follower is down hence this x right here
well it's possible actually that the
follower just has bad internet as you
can see our other follower is
criticizing him because the truth of the
matter is the leader could still be up
and running and there might just be an
issue communicating between the leader
and the follower
and so if a follower were to think the
leader is down it might want to replace
it somehow with a new leader but the
reality of the situation is it's really
hard to actually be sure that that's the
right thing to do because of the fact
that you know the network is
asynchronous we're not actually sure
when the leader is going to communicate
with the follower next so it's hard to
be sure that the leader is down so
that's one problem already and we're
going to touch upon you know probably
many videos later how we can actually
fix something like that but it's
definitely not easy and it's going to
require a lot more thinking so problem
number two is this you know you think oh
just because I have single leader
replication that you're never going to
have any lost rights right every right
goes to the leader and then eventually
it's going to be propagated right back
to the followers so every single right
is eventually going to every one of the
followers we're never going to lose any
rights right well not necessarily
because let's say we've got a leader who
on you know our replication log
the last right that it wrote when that
log was 80. and remember that those
rights are being propagated
asynchronously to the followers so if
this guy gets right number 80 and it
basically goes down because someone
pulls the plug on it and then our
follower has only seen up to right 70 in
the replication log well now we've
basically taken right 71 to 80 and just
said they don't exist
and so you know these could actually be
valuable rights you know this could be
someone's financial data this could be
my message to a baddie over Tinder
anything like that now all of a sudden
you know it's just gone it's completely
in the void and that right that you
thought was valid no longer exists
anymore so even though this leader is
you know basically you know we've taken
our follower and we've promoted him to
leader one
the issue is that doesn't actually have
all of the rights that we thought it
would and so now we have a data
Integrity issue so that's the second
issue and I'm still not even offering
any solutions at this point because
frankly it's really really hard to offer
solutions to this and so we'll discuss
that in a second
so now our third scenario is this let's
imagine we have this original leader
over here
it goes down we elect a follower as our
new leader Prime
now it loves being the leader for sure
and then all of a sudden
as if coming back from the dead our
original leader is back and now we have
two leaders
what is this known as it is called split
brand so let me go ahead and write that
down
and so split brain is when our system is
only supposed to have one liter but do
do basically just you know issues with
certain nodes coming back on certain
nodes going down we end up having two
liters and so now if we have a second
guy not only does this guy here not know
who to write to but our second guy might
write to this right leader and then the
first guy might write to the left leader
and then they're both sending rights to
all of the followers and the followers
are like what the hell where are these
rights coming from split brain clearly
if it were to happen is a major data
Integrity issue and you can be certain
that one of those two leaders is going
to have to get shut down or else chaos
can ensue so as you can see clearly
having a leader that does go down is a
massively problematic situation and
truthfully due to the fact that there's
no guarantees on when you know a network
message is going to get from a leader to
a follower or a follower back to a
leader or from a follower to a follower
it's really really hard to say oh I know
for sure that this leader is down and I
know for sure that this node is the
leader right you basically need
something called this distributed
consensus and so a distributed consensus
is saying is that you know if we got a
few databases oh my God I'm terrible at
drawing if we have a few databases
let's say we've got three of them
it means that all three even though
they're not physically the same computer
are a hundred percent sure not only of
who the leader is but whether it's up or
it's down so in this case it would be
leader and everyone agrees and this
concept distributed consensus is
something that we're going to have to
cover in detail you know a few videos
down the line but it is super important
because basically without this concept
of being able uh to agree on some sort
of consensus amongst multiple computers
we would basically have no setup for
replication that allows us to ensure the
correctness of our data and that would
obviously be super problematic so I just
wanted to show this off as a problem to
kind of set the stage for that a few
videos from now but anyways let's do a
quick conclusion of single leader
replication before we go on to our next
videos and I can doze off
so number one is like I mentioned it's
simple right if you already have a
single database turning that into a
single leader replication setup is super
easy you just add followers and it's
also simple in the sense that if a
follower goes down you can either add a
new follower and just restore it using
the replication log or you can bring
back the old follower and again restore
it using the replication log at the same
time there is quite a bit more read
throughput right if I'm in Chicago and
then you've got a bunch of idiots who
live in Australia for God knows what
reason they can easily access that data
via a replica that is located closer to
them which is very important at the same
time there are some downsides to single
leader replication we've touched already
upon like the leader going down and for
now let's assume that we do actually
have a solution for the leader going
down and that we can perform something
known as a failover where we elect a new
leader and things go well again but even
besides that assuming we can figure out
a way to elect a new leader we do have
this other problem which is this what if
we want more right throughput a lot of
applications just have a ton of Rights
and what I've only given you the option
to do right now is get more read
throughput because at the end of the day
you can have this type of setup
but what's going to happen is that your
right throughput is limited to that one
liter and so ultimately what we need to
end up doing is coming up with different
types of replication schemas that are
going to allow you to write to multiple
different places and by doing so then we
could increase our right throughput so
we're going to talk about that in the
next few videos and of course the
problems that arise when we try and do
things like that and I'm looking forward
to it guys so have a great night I will
be doing the same and I'll see you in
the next one